foreign
although the terms crypto coin crypto
token and cryptocurrency are frequently
used interchangeably they don't mean the
same thing although both coins and
tokens employ blockchain technology
there are some key distinctions between
the two and that is what I'm going to
talk about in this video hey everyone
welcome to this new coin versus token
video that will cover some major
differences between these two so let's
start the journey but before that please
do subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more such interesting topics but before
getting to the comparison of crypto
coins and tokens let me give a quick
introduction to what is a digital asset
this will help you understand the
difference between crypto coins and
tokens better broadly speaking a digital
asset is a non-tangible asset that is
created exchanged and kept in a digital
format by this definition
cryptocurrencies and crypto tokens are
considered digital Assets in the context
of blockchains since both
cryptocurrencies and tokens are digital
assets on blockchains the terms are
frequently used synonymously but they
are not similar there are multiple
parameters where they differ from each
other on multiple levels and that's what
we will cover moving forward in this
video so let me take you through the
comparison parameters based on which we
will compare crypto coins and tokens
first is definition cryptocurrencies
have their own unique blockchain BTC is
the currency used in the Bitcoin
blockchain ethereum has eth on its
blockchain similar to traditional
currencies the main purpose of these
currency coins is to serve as a form of
wealth storage and a medium of exchange
for this reason cryptocurrency is
another name for cryptocurrency coins
although they are created utilizing
blockchain technology unlike
cryptocurrency currencies crypto tokens
are not native to a blockchain while
cryptocurrency coin imitate conventional
money crypto tokens behave more like
assets or even Deeds a crypto token may
serve as a proxy for ownership the next
parameter that will be measured is
Supply the way they are created mining
is used to create crypto coins in most
cases cryptocurrencies are either mined
using a proof of work or pow or a proof
of stake POS consensus mechanism tokens
unlike cryptocurrencies are generalized
and distributed by the project developer
rather than being mined tokens Can Be
utilized in a plethora of ways once they
are in the possession of buyers now
talking about fees or gas when
transferring a cryptocurrency
transaction fees or gas are cheaper
however when transferring tokens they
are more expensive when transferring
tokens you still require some
cryptocurrency in the same account
because fees are always paid for
increase cryptocurrencies now moving on
to the next parameter purpose what are
they used for or what they serve crypto
coins are designed to work in the same
way as paper money and metal coins
meaning they can be used for many of the
things normally used with US dollars or
Euros including storing value exchanging
for other currencies paying for goods
and services transferring to others and
so forth whereas most crypto tokens are
made to be utilized in dapps or
blockchain based projects crypto tokens
Can represent ownership in a dow a
digital product or nft or even a
tangible item crypto tokens are similar
to currencies in that they may be
purchased sold and exchanged but are not
utilized as a means of exchange to put
it another way crypto coins are more
like dollars and cents whereas crypto
tokens are more like coupons or vouchers
and the last parameter that will be
measured is types the variation of
crypto coins or tokens present in the
crypto Market some of the popular crypto
coins are Bitcoin the first and most
well-known crypto coin in the world
ethereum implements smart contracts and
is the home to thousands of blockchain
projects and nfts cardano and open
source and decentralized blockchain
platform that is one of the first to run
on a POS consensus and many more in
crypto tokens some of the popular tokens
are filecoin and rweave allow users to
pay with their utility tokens for the
right to store data on their
decentralized Network maximizing the
potential of cloud storage axi Infinity
one of the best known play to earn on
the market and features a utility token
called Smooth love potions Chronos a
utility token for the crypto.com
ecosystem and there are many more tokens
available in the crypto ecosystem now
the decision of whether to purchase
coins or tokens greatly depends upon the
holder's intentions well that was all
about crypto versus token and if you
found this video interesting and
informative then please do like this
video And subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more interesting videos and
updates like this also if you have any
questions regarding this video please
feel free to ask away in our comments
section our team will reach out to you
as soon as possible thank you and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here